I grew up in the United States but to a very traditional Chinese family.
And I got married at the very old age of 38,...
...or at least it's considered very old in China.
From the time I graduated from college, at 21 to 38,...
...every week, my mom will be calling me and say,...
"Do you have a boyfriend yet?"
"When are you gonna get married?"
you know, getting very nervous.
At one point, I was the Deputy Mayor in Los Angeles,...
...she'll still be calling and say, "Why are you being a Deputy Mayor?"
"What man is going to want you now?"
I say, "Well mom, I'm trying to help millions of people have a better life..."
"...and contribute more to the economy."
and she say, "But don't you know a woman's most important role...
...is to be a wife and mother?"
When I talk to my friends here in China,...
...the one thing that I hear probably more than anything else...
...is, "I have so much pressure in my life."
Young women often say, their parents do not allow them to date through high school,...
...not want them to date through college,...
...but the second they graduated from college, they want them to get married.
There's been a tradition in let's say Western Europe...
...of individual rights, protests for maybe 500 years.
In China, there never has been that.
There's still been this sort of unifying culture of the women's role.
These women are some of the most educated people in the world right now.
And yet, all of their cultural inculcation...
...has been to look at themselves as wives and mothers.
They look at me and say, "Wow, society wants me to go in this direction."
But just by having her out there as a data point,...
...I just felt like the possibilities ahead of me just expanded.